hace 15 años Genaro García Luna era el
máximo responsable de seguridad de
México encargado de luchar contra los
cárteles de droga a sus 54 años acaba de
ser declarado culpable por un tribunal
de Nueva York por cargos relacionados
con el tráfico de drogas Genaro García
Luna secretario de seguridad pública de
México de 2006 a 2012 fue declarado
culpable hoy por un Jurado Federal en
Brooklyn y los cinco cargos de una
imputación formal que lo acusa de
participar en una continua empresa
criminal que incluye seis violaciones
relacionadas con narcotráfico
conspiración de distribución
internacional de cocaína conspiración
para poseer con intención de distribuir
cocaína conspiración para importar
cocaína y hacer declaraciones falsas
para el abogado de la ex funcionario
mexicano García Luna es víctima de la
venganza de narcos arrepentidos y de
acusaciones infundadas
estamos muy decepcionados por la
sentencia de hoy después de muchos años
de intentar construir contra el señor
García Luna compruebas creíbles y
fiables el gobierno ha tenido que
conformarse con un caso construido sobre
las espaldas de algunos de los
criminales más notorios y despiadados
para testificar en este tribunal
la caída de Genaro García Luna inició en
2019 durante el juicio contra Joaquín El
Chapo Guzmán jefe del Cartel De Sinaloa
en el un narcotraficante explicó como
había entregado millonarios sobornos a
García Luna nunca antes un funcionario
mexicano de tan alto Rango había sido
juzgado por este tipo de cargos en
Estados Unidos su condena fue aplaudida
por el gobierno del presidente mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador cuyo
portavoz se pronunció en Twitter García
Luna es declarado culpable por tráfico
de drogas delincuencia organizada y
falsedad de declaraciones en Estados
Unidos la justicia ha llegado para Quien
fuera escudero de Felipe Calderón Los
crímenes en contra de nuestro pueblo no
serán olvidados nunca la con contra
García Luna se conocerá el 27 de junio
el ex secretario de seguridad pública
podría enfrentar una pena de entre 20
años hasta la cadena